こんにちはペヤング大好きはみ社長ですえ
ペヤングさんから新作が出ました
こちらえ情報量少な今回情報量少ないん
ですよこちら和牛マフィアウルトラ
ペヤングいやすごいね和牛マフィア
ウルトラペヤングしか書いてないです情報
量すごくない本当にねマジでウルトラ
ペヤングでしかないんですよその他の情報
があまりになすぎてちょっと不安になるん
ですよ面とか見てももうこれ
だけ
なしこれ
なし裏見たらバーコードと栄養セーブル
のみ情報量がすねな何これ何このペヤング
見た時衝撃受けてたまたま昨日ファミリー
マートに行った時に売ってたんでウルトラ
ペヤングって情報俺知らなかったしどう
いうことだろうと思ってちょっとペヤング
マニアからすると混乱しましてこんなに
情報のないペヤング多分市場初です何味か
もわかんないしなんか警戒するじゃない
ですか辛いんじゃないかみたいなこの
パターン毎回辛いのでペヤングさんだけど
もどう見ても辛辛いんかなそれはない
だろうどう意でも辛い感じもなくただただ
ウルトラという文字が入ってるだけの
ペヤングなんですけど逆にこれ何このQR
から読み込めって感じなのかなそこに
なんか詳細があるんかなこれ大丈夫か
こんなに情報ないの結構初なんですけども
ちょっと見てみましょうかQR読み込んで
みますおおバギマフィアお肉のお店んです
よバギマフィアお肉とのコラボってこと
ああ情報なしだQRコード読み込んでも
情報がないですすごいぞこれマジでこんな
情報ないことある110kgカロリーも
あるのカロリーえぐいやあもう本当に謎に
満ち溢れたペヤングウルトラペヤングなん
ですけどもこれちょっとペヤング
マイスターとして外せないので早速食べて
みたいと思い
ますでは早速作ってみたいと思いますどう
したんだろうペヤングさんなんか
たどり着いたのかなもう完成しちゃった
みたいなこのヤグが一番うまいですみたい
なやつがもうできちゃったのかな火薬とか
ソースの色でなんとなくわかんのよ
おお
あななん
だガーリックとかかな結構帯び正しい量の
ガーリックが入ってますねでソースがあで
も普通そう普通だあとは何も入ってない
ですねええ振りかけとかも今回ないのか
珍しいお湯
[音楽]
豆乳オッケーこれで3分待ちましょうやば
火薬入り忘れてたややべえや俺としたこと
が久々久々すぎて忘れてたぜ作り方
をえ待ってやばくないなんかガーリックの
量があオケーオッケーはいこれでこれで3
分待ちますなんか俺これ食べる前に
ちょっとネットで見たんですけど
[音楽]
も今来た
わああ
すげえ
これすごいわこれネットで見たんですけど
もウルトラペヤングも先に言うんですけど
もあのやばいらしいです何がやばいかって
今の反応で分かりましたかあの
ね
[音楽]
うわああ左あのね匂いが匂いがすごいん
ですよ人肉のそれもあのそんななんか生半
かなさニンニクマシマシの美味しいです
みたいなそんなのじゃなくてもうなんか
マジでぶっ壊れてるぐらいのニンニク
らしいんですよもう新発売で最近発売し
たっぽいんですけどもなんか口コミとか
見るとあの結構すごいとニンニク好きな人
からすると分かんないかもしんないです
けどなんか常人からするともうなんか
美味しいを超えてるんじゃないかみたいな
そういうなんかネットの情報を見ました
どういうレベルなのニンニクって入れたら
美味しくなるもんじゃないのちょっとゆ
切ってきますどのレベルなん
だろうよ切り
ますこれさ密封してるうちはまだ大丈夫
そうなんだよなはいお湯切ってきました
さあ開きますよ行き
ますうちょっと待っ
てああこれソースはどんなの使われてるん
だソースかけ
ますえこれソースも普通のペヤングのソス
じゃないぞ
多分ライスはしライスのようなソースが
入ってましたねうわすごい
めっちゃうわあああすごいすごいこれ
やばいこれ大丈夫かすごいぞ匂いテロの
あの美味しいの方じゃなくてマジの
ニンニクの匂いテロの方だぞ
これちょっと待って
すっごああすごい待って
これそうかペヤングさんこれがウルトラ
ペヤングですかこれすごいぞあやばいもう
ねこれ食べる前から分かるんですけど俺が
今まで食べてきたニニ料理のどのニンニク
料理よりもニンニクですねうんいやなせ
ニンニクがもうかなりやばいレベルで強烈
ですあ
やばい分かるかな匂いで匂いで汗かい
ちゃうもうはい完成しましたペヤング自体
はこういう感じですねシンプルな焼きそば
まだ食べてないから何とも言えないんです
けどもこれウルトラペヤング辛いとかそう
いうのじゃなくてえもうニンニクニンニク
を限界まで入れたみたいな感じなんじゃ
ないかなちょっとニュース見てみよう
ひどいなガーリックたっぷりペヤング思わ
ず周囲も振り返るって書いてあるるかな
めっちゃ汗かいてんのよもう女の子と会え
なくなっちゃう女の子と合えなくなる
どころがこれどんな匂になってしまうんだ
これちょっと早速食べてみたいと思います
味がが味もねなんかネットで見る限り
すごい賛否両論というかもう本当に
ニンニク好きじゃないと無理みたいな
レベルらしいんですよ果たしていかほどの
ものかそ僕ニンニクはあの普通ぐらいです
めっちゃ好きでもないですし嫌いでもない
ですしちょっと好きぐらいのニンニクに
対しは普通の感情を委たく人間ですでは
ペヤング
ウルトラいただき
[音楽]
ます
鼻をつんざく鼻をつんざくにおいたな
いただき
[音楽]
ます
ああストロング私の感想はこれストロング
ですね強烈あと知らんけどめっちゃ汗書い
てきたんだけど伝わるかなこれもこれ汗顔
ももうテカテカなんですよわかるあるかな
めっちゃ汗かいてますなんか知んないけど
とりあえず味はねちょっともうちょっと
食べてみたてわかんない人口はとりあえず
なんかパワーを感じまし
た
ううああすごい辛いとか全くないんです
けどもうなんかもう近寄った時に匂いなん
ですけどなんか物理的な壁を感じるんです
よオーラが出てる結か貼られてる
これあすごい悪魔的
だなんでこんな俺汗かいてだろネットだと
なんか散々言われてますけど個人的な評価
させていただき
ますこれを食べた後えその日何もなければ
あり
ですあのね分かるのよこのニンニクに
埋もれる幸せを極限まで目指した感じただ
ねもう匂いがやばいのよ本当に多分俺
やばいのよちょ誰かに誰かにちょっと匂い
かかせて
みようにいにににい
くえすごく
ないすごえやばくないこれ
やばいせちゃっ
たえ食べるのあ味ね感想をちょっと一通り
確か臭いもんはうまいって決まってるんで
そうなのよいただき
ますうまいああやばうまい花だか
めちゃめちゃ好きあナチ好きなのね好き
うわあえくくさいや臭いっていう
かちょっと鼻おかしくなってきちゃった
あれニニ好きじゃないっけ普通ニンニクは
普通ですうじゃあいただきますお願いし
ますたくさんいっちゃいなもうがっつり
がっつりいっちゃいますよじゃおすげえ
いただき
ます
うん
[拍手]
部屋草自分の部屋くやばい部屋がなんか
トキシックな匂に包まれてるこれやばいわ
食べた人どこじゃなくて食べた空間後と
これニンニになりますねだいぶ減ったので
ちょっと食いますよ
う
うんうんごめんちょっとけど完食しました
ああ
やばい
ああ自分だとわからんいやさすがペヤング
さん素晴らしいですウルトラペヤングって
言われて何が出てくるんだろうかと散々
もう行かれた商品を出し続けてウルトラ
ペヤング何なんだろうただの美味しい
焼きそばですかとか思ったんですけども
ちゃんとハードルを超えてきましたこれ
史上を割れに見る
あのあの悪い意味でのテロ本当のあの匂い
の危ない方のメシテロですこれとんでも
ない物を作りましたねペヤングさんこれ
多分そのラーメン屋さんとか行く時に
ニンニクマシマに食べる人とか食べると
普通にこれ決まります飛ぶニンニクそんな
好きじゃない人が食べるとこれはマジで
病院毒入りを食らったかのような匂いの
散乱の仕方ですごいの作ったすねウルトラ
ペヤングいや常識をまた1つペヤングさ
超えましたねおめでとうございますこれ
食べると1日終わっちゃうので食べる
タイミングは皆さんぜひ気をつけてみて
くださいニンニク好きの方はぜひ経験して
みてはいかがでしょうかえしばらく僕には
誰も近づかないで
[音楽]
ください